what was that study that looked at
penalty takers trying to win versus
penalty takers trying not to lose or
trying to catch up on the scoresheet
yeah it's very interesting that so there
was a study which looked at
um what people and obviously England
we've got to World Cup coming up
um uh next month I don't have a God's
sake don't ask me about that mate
um but um yeah there was a study done
which looked at who was most likely to
score penalties in a penalty shootout
and you know most people watching a
penalty shootout would think that the
pressure is equally high on everybody
uh but actually when you look and you
you kind of analyze it there's different
pressures depending on whether you are
taking a penalty to keep your team in
the competition
or whether you are taking a penalty to
put your team through uh so if you're
taking a penalty to put your team
through uh the pressure is actually less
than uh the pressure on you if you're
taking a penalty to keep your team in
because our brains have evolved a bias
towards loss rather than reward
um if you think back to our evolutionary
history if you face with a rustle in the
bushes and you make a wrong decision and
you think oh well that's nothing
um then it can come out of the Bush and
eat you pretty quickly it might not be
the breeze it might be a saber-toothed
tiger
um so actually our brains have evolved a
bias towards loss aversion we don't want
to make a mistake we don't want to have
a a situation where we are complacent
and where we mistake something uh which
is eventually going to eat us so which
is going to lose us our lives so those
kinds of evolutionary buyers biases that
evolved many years ago are still with us
today in in football stadiums when it
comes to penalty shootout so if you're
taking a penalty which if you miss is
going to put your team out that loss is
really Weighing on your mind way more
than if you know you're going to score
and you're going to put your team
through the stakes at least the way the
brain computes it Chris are much higher
if you're taking a penalty to stay in do
you know what the relative percentages
are I think it's something like off the
top of my head mate I think it's
something like 62 of people
Gore
uh when it's putting when you're taking
a penalty to uh keep your team in and I
think it's roughly about 90 score when
it's uh taken penalty to put your team
through uh so it's something like that
it's something like 60 90. so it's still
the majority of people score but when
you're putting your when you're taking a
pill and you put your team through
way more people score I suppose although
if you're talking about England mate I'm
not sure maybe that study maybe that
study doesn't want wasn't done in
England yeah this is never
um yeah what that means is
when you're doing a normal penalty
shootout let's say that you're into the
um knockout stages of a competition and
you get to the end there is a huge
Advantage there is a 30 advantage to the
team that gets to take the penalties
first let's say that each team continues
to score
that's right it's 4-4 with the final two
penalties to go you've got it team one
misses and team two scores yeah team one
is out but Team One never faces the
situation game theoretically of that 30
disparity between the success or failure
uh concern so there is a huge I mean
that's the most important way more
important than who which end do you get
who gets to kick off first the most
important thing perhaps in an entire
competition is who gets to take the
penalties first it's it's a literally is
who wins the toss you're absolutely
right that that um that a what we call
in Psychology interact uh you know that
who wins that chart interacts with you
know your ability uh to actually score
penalty shootouts are very interesting
there's a lot of you a lot of how you
can almost have a degree in penalty
shootouts you know you could almost like
set up an entire degree course in it
um there's loads and loads of different
ways the penalty shootout can go wrong
how things pray on the mind
um the best thing to do in a penalty
shootout
is well first of all to practice them
which England are now doing that's the
first thing Chris uh the second thing is
to make your mind up and just go for it
so literally
um a lot of penalties are missed not in
the runner which uh people think is is
often the case but actually the penalty
is often missed when you put the ball
down if you imagine a player if you put
the ball down and then you turn around
and you walk away from the ball to a
point where you're going to begin your
run-up
and that point in that when you put the
ball down and you turn away and You
Begin the walk to your run-up that is
when it goes wrong most of the time
because that's all of a sudden when last
minute doubts or changes of mind can
creep in
um all that kind of noise uh that that
usually disrupts the clarity of thought
uh that can creep in and you can change
your mind at the last minute without you
even knowing you're gonna do it so the
way around that is to absolutely decide
from the word go no matter what happens
it's top left bottom right or what have
you
um from a psychological point of view
that's the best way of winning a penalty
shootout to be absolutely confident to
be absolutely certain what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]